jours de manifestations dans l'hexagone
des actions sont prévues un peu partout
dans le pays comme ici à l'aéroport
charles de gaulle elle les associations
alternatiba et actions non violentes
comme 21 réclament une réduction du
trafic aérien
un plan de reconversion du secteur et
l'abandon des projets d'extension comme
à roissy
la crise du coronavirus aclu et de
nombreux avions au sol et 15 milliards
d'euros ont été bloqués par le
gouvernement pour relancer le secteur
dont près de la moitié pour la compagnie
air france attend cette action pour nous
elle est essentielle parce qu'il faut
aujourd'hui faire en sorte que le
secteur aérien se soumettent lui aussi à
l'impératif climatique et participe à
l'effort collectif de lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique
aujourd'hui le secteur aérien on estime
que c'est au moins 7 % de l'empreinte
carbone de la france et surtout ça va
augmenter à l'avenir dès lors que cette
crise sanitaire va être terminée on sait
que les créoles les compagnies aériennes
se prépare à relancer d'innombrables
avions dans le ciel et que ce secteur là
va peser de plus en plus dans l'équation
le climatique il faut réduire
aujourd'hui et supprimer les vols courts
dès lors qu'il ait des alternatives
entre impossible il faut faire en sorte
que le secteur aérien soit moins
impactant sur le pour le pour le climat
et l'environnement
on lutte contre les extensions
d'aéroport on n'est pas opposé au trafic
aérien
on est opposé à la croissance infinie
est folle de ce trafic nous emmène dans
le mur c'est également la raison pour
laquelle on fait partie du collectif
opposé à la construction du terminal 4
qui est prévu par adp qui représenterait
l'équivalent de orly et roissy le
secteur de l'aviation essaye de nous
faire croire qu'il est porteur d'
énormément d'emplois qui les préserve
alors qu'on voit qu air france vient de
bénéficier d'un plan à hauteur de 7
milliards et qu'en parallèle il annonce
7 mai licenciement donc on voit
qu'aujourd'hui les entreprises n'ont
qu'un intérêt il ne cherche pas à
protéger leurs employés